I like the way certain directors  approach genre and try to kind of  mythologize and make it their own  whether it be Sergio Leone going into  westerns and then creating a world of  his own with westerns and then even with  uh outfits whether it be the long  dusters that they wore and uh the Poncho  that the man with no name wore and the  kind of almost Union outfit that Lee Van  Cleef would wear so when I came along it  was my thing was to establish my own  sets of style and my own sense of like a  coat of armor for them and mine was the  black suits that was the thing is in  Reservoir Dogs and Reservoir Dogs is a  practical reason why I have them wear  black suits but by the time Pulp Fiction  came around it's more like no that's  just my style oh my guys wear black suit  and it's like Melville's trench coats or  like John moose pigeons or uh Leone's  dusters it was kind of my sense of style  that I was trying to bring to the genre